jd was quite concerned that his body
will die but we don't know for sure
he says our brains might survive we
could be
in eternity thinking in there in the
casket or wherever
hell we are is that it jd do i have it
right
i mean pretty much at least you know i
don't think it's forever but because i
think
you know things decay but yeah how long
are you just laying there and possibly
knowing you're just laying there i don't
know
how does the brain stay alive without a
heart jd
right in other words there's no blood
pumping to the brain
[Laughter]
listen i'm not exactly i thought uh you
know
just because your heart stops your brain
doesn't exactly die
immediately like your brain needs blood
well okay but there are also like
electrical
uh surges or whatever going on up there
uh
you know so how long do those last
like you're not you are not technically
dead until you are brain dead
right and they know how long that takes
because they have
machines that can measure that but again
these machines and the research can only
do so much they can only
know so they can you think that you'll
still be thinking at a low
level of brain activity too low to
register
on an electro encephalogram possibly
you no one knows anything after you die
because
you don't come back from the dead and
you don't know so that's
wow there's a lot of thoughts going on
there and i and i play
this because i think this sums it up
quarantine
thoughts with jd meyer
i i think yeah i thought about a lot
lately is your brain
still being alive while you're dead like
you're just sort of
what can you still feel while you're
dead and you can't emote
or whatever something in you
but you just can't emote it or whatever
you just can't you know
because you don't fully know because
you're dead
you can't really research that because
you would have to be dead
to fully know a remnants of
brain energy and matter or whatever is
still coursing through
you know still it's something i've
thought like i could be laying in the
casket
and not being able to move or anything
and know that i'm laying in the casket
and just nothing is happening nothing
nothing has happened nothing to
i don't think anything's happening right
now